the Bejeweled Taylor Swift moment
because for me this is the legend that
you are your line tired tacky wench is
that what got you on board is that like
because for me if I read that I got to
say that to Taylor I would that would
get me on board tell me how that came
about well even better is when she's
speaking to you on the phone asking you
if there's any way you could possibly be
willing to say these words to her
because preceding a script we were just
talking on the phone about ideas she's
like what if you called me I'm like I'm
in I'm definitely doing it so she wrote
that line for you to call her
yes that is perfect yeah it was amazing
oh my God I am honored to be part of it
and so excited for this amazing moment
of triumphant success for her truly
truly we're all proud of Taylor we're
all swifties in our hearts yes just
really wish you were here yeah
yeah the White Lotus this phone Outburst
moment I must bring it up how did it
come about and does it lend itself to
potential for a cameo down the line of
the Season Mike White and I made the
show enlightened together and we're
artistic family and so you know I'm I
think it's such a brilliant show and
what he's made is incredible and he's
the most incredible writer ever I just
you know I love his brain and so
you know all he had to do was ask I
wouldn't be surprised if we find our way
to each other again in our lives for now
I'm just excited to be on the phone
we're excited just to have you on the
phone
I read this and I went this isn't
surreal to me but I'm going to ask it to
you
is it surreal to hear Legend and Laura
Dern in the same sentence surreal it's
not surreal to me you've been a legend
since I've ever seen you on TV ever on a
movie ever well you're very sweet it's
incredibly generous and a little
hilarious and I'm you know honored and
happy to be here yes describe
um a defining moment in your career
where
you hit a high point maybe that you
never thought you would reach I would
say
spend the opportunity
in
or The Art of Storytelling where you're
on a set and you're looking at a
favorite filmmaker and thinking oh my
God I'm working with David Lynch or the
people who have Steven Spielberg who've
inspired me so much in my career I would
say the most incredible all-time high is
sinning at dinner with your co-stars and
your actors
having a meal after a hard work day and
turning around and it's all women that
you've admired all your life
and you're all peers and you're just
making art together and stuff together
which I would say with the cast of Big
Little Lies who've become my dearest
friends sure that is an all-time high
because you can't believe it or working
with my parents which I've had the
privilege of doing too so in a way it's
like the people you work with is the is
the ultimate how about the best piece of
advice you've had through your career to
to play the long game to have longevity
and keep riding it out without you know
potentially making a bad decision Mrs
White my fourth grade teacher said keep
your eyes on your own paper
Mrs White I love their advice for all of
us and it really runs deep if you think
about it runs deep runs deep let's just
stick with our plan and not you know not
compare and not get caught up right
comparison is the thief of Joy I don't
know who said it but it's a great
question I think you just said and I am
you're now my mentor
[Music]